would this game scare you
what about
this game mario
mario
or
what about this
today we'll take a look at a timeline of
games that have defined horror
throughout history these games have
either innovated on the genre and served
as a pillar for other games to replicate
or master what has come before
representing the best of what the genre
can offer
so let's dive into 13 games that defined
horror
[Laughter]
stop stop stop stop with the lights cut
it out
stop
technically speaking the first horror
game was on 1972's magnavox odyssey this
was a horror game titled haunted house
which involved putting one of these
overlays over graphics like these
chilling but i wouldn't really call that
a horror game the advent of text-based
adventure games like 1976's colossal
cave adventure and 1977 zork would bring
about a change with a better way to
present horror enter sierra online and
mystery house
now this game truly was revolutionary
ken and roberto williams added graphics
onto the text-based adventure genre
creating the first visual pc horror game
in 1980 at the time there were visuals
in some pc games and the williams were
inspired by previous text adventure
games but these ideas hadn't really been
combined before ken williams was able to
convert drawings roberto williams had
created to add visual scenes above the
text to show players where they were and
what followed was pretty much the only
true horror genre
at first unlike action style games you
can still create a sense of tension and
horror with good writing take 1987's the
lurking horror which at the time was
compared by some critics to have strong
enough writing to resemble stephen king
or h.p lovecraft while mystery house
isn't remembered too well today it does
have a historical legacy and that it
combined a visual aid with a text-based
story to create a spooky atmosphere it
was something other early horror games
could use as a template especially with
the limited technology of the time
next we fast forward in 1989
this game is pretty interesting to me
because as much as i grew up on video
games and centered my life around them i
didn't know about it until researching
for this list
and that game is sweet home i hope
you'll forgive me because as it turns
out i probably didn't know about sweet
home because it actually never released
outside of japan
sweet home was based on a film of the
same name and no not the modern day
manual and subsequent show
in it you play as five documentary
filmmakers who are trapped in a spooky
haunted mansion by a ghost and forced to
try and get out the characters could
perma-dye affecting the ending you'd
have to solve puzzles using items you
found around the mansion to escape and
you had a limited inventory if any of
this sounds at all familiar it's because
the game's director tokuro fujiwara
would later go on to produce a far more
well-known game which used sweet home as
its basis and inspiration
resident evil
[Music]
also those door loading screens from
resident evil yeah that was awesome
sweet home
while most people think of resident evil
when they think of classic 3d survival
horror really the game's roots were a
combination of sweet home and another
major game
alone in the dark this game first
released for ms-dos in 1992 was the
first 3d survival horror game
now this might come as a shock at this
point
but the game takes place in a creepy
mansion i'm starting a list for how many
games i mentioned take place in a creepy
mansion
so far we have three alone in the dark
wasn't just horror in 3d but featured
many mainstays of survival horror you
couldn't kill every enemy could choose
to avoid them and had a limited
inventory with the game focused on
puzzle solving while the game's monsters
admittedly weren't all that scary the
main female protagonist you could choose
to play as looked like
this
also uve bull optioned and made an alone
in the dark film and if that isn't
horrifying i don't know what is
my mommy says that there's nothing to be
afraid of in the dark your mother's
wrong kid
being afraid of the dark is what keeps
most of us alive
really though alone in the darks usage
of a creepy mansion to explore with
unexpected terrors and an underpowered
protagonist would serve as a basis for
many horror games to come after all part
of what makes scary games well scary is
the fear that you aren't powerful enough
to deal with the spooky situation in
front of you and very well might die
[Music]
seventh yes
it's the seventh guest another creepy
mansion game
but this one was absolutely [ __ ]
terrifying fun fact about me ghosts are
one of the few things that actually
scare me and a game that takes place in
a mansion with fmv ghosts everywhere no
thank you
which is one of the things that made the
seventh guest stand out so much the
seventh guests utilize pre-rendered 3d
graphics and live action full motion
video or fmv to make its mansion look
far creepier and more realistic than any
game before it unlike the previous games
the seventh guest was also first person
similar to the previous games the game
involved the player solving various
puzzles while the puzzles were
oftentimes completely unrelated to the
overarching story and some were
insane don't even get me started on the
cans puzzle it did set forth the
precedent of first-person puzzle horror
games and just oozed in creepy
atmosphere while miss tends to get the
nod for this sort of technology seventh
guest actually released earlier in 1993
than missed this became the norm for
many horror games in the early to mid
90s games like phantasmagoria d or the
game that personally gave me horrible
nightmares
shivers
so the next game takes place in a creepy
mansion can you guess it based on the
previous games
it is impossible to talk about horror
games without mentioning resident evil
this is one of the most influential
horror games of all time and while it
took elements from alone in the dark and
sweet home which it was originally going
to be a remake of resident evil came to
define what a survival horror was and
was spearheaded by shinji makami capcom
also coined the term survival horror to
promote resident evil which is still the
term we use for this genre fun story
about shinji mikami in an interview with
tokuro fujiwara who had pitched the
project as a 3d remake of sweet home he
states that he partially chose to put
shinji mikami in charge because mikami
hated being scared and was reluctant
therefore mikami would know what was
scary like i don't know maybe dogs
jumping out of a window to kill you in
your room you previously explored as i
was safe
just a thought i had i don't know why
resident evil focused on zombies and
utilize tight corridors and limited ammo
to heighten the sense of terror and
dread at what could otherwise be a slow
moving less intense enemy add to this
that your character had to stop moving
in order to shoot enemies and you
couldn't properly aim
[Music]
as i talked about previously by making
your character less powerful you're able
to ramp up a sense of fear by doing
these steps it was far more challenging
to kill zombies you might not have
enough ammo you might try to shoot for
their head and miss therefore wasting
ammo as you were in crammed corridors
you were far less likely to be able to
avoid the zombies in your path all of
this making it far more likely you
wouldn't survive and the game would
surprise you with ambushes that would
take you off guard sending you into a
state of panic the game was an
absolutely massive success spawning one
of the most prolific horror video game
franchises to date still going strong
today after the game was released
anything remotely resembling it was
quickly labeled as an re clone or
something inspired by resident evil
i'm going to give you a clue the next
game
doesn't take place in a mansion while
the series backbone is similar to
resident evil in its 3d survival horror
it became distinct thanks to his focus
on psychological horror i'm talking of
course about silent hill
or more specifically in this case silent
hill 2. as i mentioned silent hill was
unique from resident evil in that it
focused more on the psychological the
game used sound atmosphere and tension
to create a sense of horror while
playing along with the stories of these
games tackling darker more personal
matters the world of silent hill 2 is
enveloped in fog and while this was
actually something done due to the
technological limitations of the time
the lack of sight and awareness of
what's around only helped to deepen the
sense of dread and the unknown and
seriously the soundtrack to this game is
terrifying on its own comprising of
atonal music and things like drill
sounds to make it as unpleasant and
unnerving as possible merrimack bonesby
do you want to explain this one
but unlike the previous games it didn't
help reinvent the horror genre and
silent hill 2 in particular is known for
its expertise in mastering the survival
horror genre in an artistic and
meaningful way silent hill 2 focuses on
the sins and psyche of his protagonist
with the monsters of the game
representing these elements like grief
and guilt with the series most famous
monster pyramid head originating from
this game as a manifestation of silent
hill 2's protagonist james feeling the
need for punishment to atone for his
sins
one game without creepy mansions we are
on a roll next up eternal darkness
okay to be fair eternal darkness's plot
actually spans the globe and much of the
game doesn't take place in a creepy
mansion
but that's the main setting of the game
and you'll often return to it the reason
being check out that segue pretty nice
right
[Music]
the reason being eternal darkness is
very specifically a lovecraftian horror
and will involve you reading what's for
all intents and purposes a necronomicon
and has you take control of other people
who have read this accursed tome while
2002's eternal darkness wasn't the
best-selling game it did do something
unique in dealing with how to include
lovecraftian elements
that being a sanity meter as the
character's sanity drops and they go
deeper into madness over the existential
dread of eternal darkness various sanity
effects will take place that break the
fourth wall this could be something as
simple as more sound effects and creepy
noises to the game pretending to lower
the volume of your tv or even pretending
to delete your save making you as a
player feel like you're going insane
[Music]
isn't too happening
it was a truly groundbreaking idea and
one that i wish received more attention
so i'm going to honor it here on this
list my quest to play cyberpunk 2077
began with buying it on a physical
medium you see i'm one of those relics
of an old age this can't be happening
what's a horrorless without a good outer
space themed horror and dead space has
embodied what good sci-fi horror is it's
a verse the idea of zombie horror where
the enemy needs to be shot in the head
with players instead needing to shoot
off enemies limbs this ratchets up the
tension as limbs are a much smaller and
more challenging target to hit
especially as the creatures dropped to
the ground and just kept crawling at you
dead space perfectly utilized its
spaceship the ishimura to create a
haunting atmosphere the ship allowed for
tight corridors giving players a sense
of claustrophobia and plenty events for
the horrifying aliens to crawl out of
thematically speaking the game also
deals with overzealous religious ideas
and the consequences of it now i want to
point out despace wasn't necessarily the
most influential game if we're talking
about influential then resident evil 4
would get the nod as despace was
directly inspired by re4 and literally
designed to be resident evil 4 but in
space
resident evil 4 completely redefined how
to create a survival horror with a new
action based version of this that dead
space jacked and as much as i love
resident evil 4 it's overshadowed by the
first game and series as a whole in
terms of representing horror but by
taking the elements that made resident
evil 4 strong adding in tight corridors
and horrific sci-fi creatures whose
weaknesses were their limbs dead space
took what resident evil 4 established
and made a horror game that came to
represent terror in space
take the sanity of eternal darkness
combine it with first person puzzle
solving of the seventh guest add some
modern elements and what do you get
amnesia the dark descent
this game
surprisingly doesn't take place in a
creepy mansion even though the creepy
castle is sort of like one while eternal
darkness's sanity meter focused on
witnessing monsters amnesia's sanity
meter adds an element of fear of the
dark to it and while eternal darkness
was a fairly easy game the combination
of first person in amnesia and much more
intense monsters you couldn't kill
absolutely skyrocketed the level of
terror amnesia could achieve the game's
reputation for fear also helped start
the careers of a couple small youtubers
who've you probably never heard of whose
less plays of the game would help bring
them to prominence
pewdiepie and markiplier and thanks to
youtube gamers the legacy of amnesia has
lived on an entire subgenre of horror
based around the ideas present in
amnesia has become a mainstay in horror
games created today
games like outlast soma and layers of
fear all take inspiration from
amnesia while working on a teaser for an
upcoming silent hills hideo kojima was
interviewed saying that while he knows
gamers can turn off a game at any point
and stop playing it if it got too scary
he didn't care he wanted to make the
scariest game possible what that
resulted in was pt
a playable teaser meant to tease an
upcoming silent hill sequel he would be
working on
but was sadly cancelled
this teaser was pure nightmare fuel and
despite being short so long as you could
solve insanely obtuse puzzles pt has
been recognized as exactly what kojima
intended one of the most frightening
experiences in gaming it brought forth a
whole new level of atmospheric horror
with a strong use of lighting to make
every corner dark and every changing
color dramatic the game featured no
music but rather sound effects that
would play as you walked forward and
different noises ramping up the tension
as you looped from room to room minor
things would change meaning you would
actually be on the lookout for little
details with every realization that a
ghost is trapped in there with you being
all the more terrifying
and speaking of that ghost lisa wasn't
just a ghost but an unsettling body
horror version of a ghost and unsettling
to look at even when she's not popping
out at you
thanks to this despite pt being removed
from the playstation's store after
silent hills was cancelled fans have
regularly called out for a silent hill
sequel specifically helmed by hideo
kojima the teaser has gone on to inspire
full-fledged games similar to it in
style and many were quick to point out
that resident evil 7 was strikingly
similar in style to pt
apparently resident evil 7 was already
in development before pt was released
and not inspired by the game but it just
goes to show the incredible fur the
teaser brought forth
[Music]
after creating over 70 fairly
unsuccessful games many times creating
four or more games in a year scott
cawthorne struck gold when he decided to
use unsettling animatronics for his jump
scare game five nights at freddy's in
2014
the game has since become an absolute
phenomenon while the jump scares stood
out it also included scraps of plot the
player was fed creating a cult-like
following seeking to discover all of
fnaf's secrets and the game theorists
kind of becoming a five nights at
freddy's channel five nights has become
so huge that not only does it have
merchandise but blumhouse productions
the film company behind insidious the
purge and many other modern horror
franchises purchased the rights to
create a five nights at freddy's film
imagine if you took the mystery and qte
based gameplay of heavy rain but mixed
it with a dash of horror that is exactly
what 2015's until dawn did it focused on
making a cinematic style game where
players were asked to quickly respond to
choices or actions that could result in
the immediate or eventual death of the
main characters the player would take
control of the idea of this design was
that unlike in horror movies where
viewers can question the character's
logic and choices in a game the player
is making the choices themselves
therefore they can empathize more with
each character and care about them more
when an untimely death may occur despite
little marketing from publisher sony
super massive's mystery slasher title
saw a massive wave of success in part
thanks to streamers and youtubers who
latched onto it the game was so
successful that supermassive created an
ongoing horror anthology series titled
the dark pictures anthology with annual
installments
finally we come to my lucky number 13
doki doki literature club meaning 6 out
of the 13 games took place in a spooky
mansion maybe that's what modern horror
games are missing doki doki literature
club presents itself as a
straightforward anime dating sim visual
novel your character is invited to your
high school's literature club which just
happens to be filled with cute anime
girls of differing generic personalities
who are all extremely interested in you
the game starts simple enough with you
writing poems and using these to try and
romance the girls of the game i don't
want to spoil too much in case you want
to play the game and haven't but the
game eventually breaks the fourth wall
with characters directly addressing you
the player and aware they're in a video
game this leads to them deleting and
moving game files on your actual
computer which you'll need to physically
leave the game locate and move in order
to progress
in a way it breaks down barriers similar
to pony island these meta elements serve
to create a sense of unease and horror
as the characters become more aware of
their existence in the player with the
player losing control over the game it's
a much different type of horror than
i've previously mentioned hence why it
felt like it deserved a spot
there are other games that definitely
could deserve a spot but i'm going to
mention here instead for this list i
tried to not just take into account my
personal tastes but also how influential
the games were but i might have left out
games that define this genre for you or
haunted your childhood maybe that's
clock tower fatal frame or the evil
within series there are also games that
aren't technically horror but had
moments that scared the crap out of me
like mist with his surprisingly creepy
vibes and king's field i'm looking at
you termites nest
and as much as i absolutely adore the
castlevania series i left out those
games because while you could classify
them as horror action horror games like
these aren't particularly scary
they're just awesome
so there you have 13 games that defined
horror what do you think deserves that
definition is it games that inspired
others to follow in its path or games
that mastered its craft thanks to the
games that came before it let me know in
the comments below what you think and if
there's any horror games you think i
should play and i'll see you guys next
time later
[Music]
you